I'm very lucky I understand where
families kind of go their own ways yeah
we're all very much alike in a way that
I know it's a lucky thing you don't that
just doesn't happen yes I know family
Dynamics are hard some people can't let
[__] go you know and then other people
come into your F my dad used to always
say my dad says things that I don't
think he realizes are good but he
also it's always sounds a little [__]
up so he's like it's not the he'd like
be next to my mom he's like he go it's
not the family that argues it's the
people that marry in and rip you
apart he's right he's right and he is
right I don't know if you say that next
to my
mom the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
zler